bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat dans quelques minutes à
peu près un petit quart d'heure nous
allons pouvoir suivre en direct les
questions d'actualité nous sommes jeudi
ce sont les traditionnelles questions
d'actualité au gouvernement est avec
nous pendant un quart d'heure pour
débattre de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire alain vidalies str bonjour
ministre en charge des relations avec le
parlement
alors on va aborder évidemment toute
cette fin de session avant les vacances
on va dire au revoir avant la trêve on
va aborder les questions parlementaires
et politiques mais d'abord on a entendu
sur nos antennes à l'instant françois
hollande qui était devant les
parlementaires en algérie au cours de sa
visite qui a dit pas n'excusent pas de
repentance mais une reconnaissance
finalement de ce qui s'est passé pendant
cette époque coloniale est ce qu'il ne
pouvait pas aller plus loin françois
hollande
je crois que ce n'était pas nécessaire
je pense qu'aujourd'hui le temps est
passé et il faut mettre des mots sur
l'histoire
vous savez combien on a eu de
difficultés pour mettre des mots sur
cette histoire
pour dire que c'était une guerre on a
passé des décennies à dire que c'était
des opérations de maintien de l'ordre il
a fallu une loi sous un gouvernement de
gauche pour dire non c'était une guerre
et aujourd'hui par les rebelles jarry a
guère il fallait mettre les mauves à
l'émail les mots or il fallait mettre un
nom sur cet égard on a refusé de le
faire pendant longtemps et mettra en ont
aujourd'hui sur la colonisation s'était
pas que la france
la colonisation c'est un des grands
événements du 19e siècle et la
décolonisation je pense que c'est ça le
mot fort un des grands événements du
début du 20e siècle et et on choisit pas
son histoire les mettre des mots sur
cette histoire c'est important mais
cette reconnaissance des souffrances et
qu est-ce que c'est une façon de
s'excuser en quelques mots ou pas pas du
tout pas du tout mais même si on ne
connaît aujourd'hui les noms les mots
comme vous l'avez dit l'impression que
c'est aussi une façon de faire sans
faire du pragmatisme la hollande n'est
pas du tout choix qu'il faut pas non non
pas du tout je crois qu'il ya dans cette
affaire et vous le savez les mots ont
leur importance et l'évolution des mots
aussi et c'est mollasson juste parler de
colonisation parler de décolonisation
parler de guerre d'algérie c'est parler
à ceux qui ont subi la colonisation mais
c'est aussi parler à tous ces français
qui étaient sur cela
r il estimait être la leur et qu'ils ont
aussi connu des souffrances terribles
dans cette période
est ce que vous estimez que ce qui s'est
passé ce matin suffira aujourd'hui à
tourner la page et faire avancer les
deux pays notamment pour différents
contrats ou en tout cas on imagine des
meilleures relations entre la france et
l'algérie qu'elle ne sont aujourd'hui à
je pense que ça va améliorer les choses
c'était c'était indispensable ces deux
pays en même temps ils n'ont pas choisi
mais ils ont cette histoire commune et
c'est vrai qu'on peut se dire que ce
qu'on a été capable de faire avec
l'allemagne
aujourd'hui il faut être capable de le
faire avec l'algérie à la vie d'alice en
a maintenant passé à l'actualité
politique et parlementaire
je voudrais juste vous montrer la une du
journal le monde
il s'agit du mariage gay est évidemment
de ce texte cet amendement qui a été
votée hier par les députés socialistes
sur la procréation médicale assistée
visiblement bien peu de tirage dans
votre corps à gauche on se divise sur la
procréation assistée il y à une pétition
de 27 députés socialistes qui veulent se
retirer
finalement de ce vote de l'amendement et
qui disent nous on ne veut pas de cet
amendement c'est trop tôt je suis là
pour représenter le gouvernement
l'association cette exposition est
ouvert le mort le gouvernement a adopté
un texte est soumis au parlement et qui
ne comporte pas la paix m
le choix de départ c'était de pas le
mettre dans le texte le parlement est
respecté il ya un débat qui s'ouvre à
l'intérieur du groupe socialiste le
gouvernement a dit que dans certaines
limites
et si le groupe socialiste se mettaient
d'accord dans des conditions qu'il
définira pour déposer cet amendement
gouvernement s'en remettra à la sagesse
du parlement
c'est une situation tout à fait normal
en démocratie mais parce qu'il ya quand
même une braise qui viennent s'ouvrir
dans la majorité
non et je pense qu'il ya un vrai débat
et c'est normal sur ces sujets c'est pas
des sujets faciles et que derrière cette
question il y ait des convictions
personnelles qui s'exprimeront n'est pas
c'est plutôt surprenant que ça n'ouvre
aucun débat et qui y est je dirais une
position univoque à droite je voulais
tant à ce que dit le monde ils disent
ses députés ces députés frondeurs comme
on les appelle que ça ne faisait pas
partie des 60 d'engagement de françois
hollande donc ça n'a rien à faire
aujourd'hui dans les sujets sociétaux
qu'on est en train d'aborder vous savez
les engagements ils sont tenus c'est le
texte est divisé par le nombre de
demandes est ce que c'est une priorité
ce texte ou pas la vie d'alice vous
savez y est la question que pose
l'amendement du groupe socialiste est
légitime puisque aujourd'hui on propose
le mariage et l'adoption
l'adoption d'enfants notamment pour les
couples femmes homosexuelles c'est une
hypocrisie finalement de se dire
l'enfant va pouvoir être adoptée sans
qu'on se pose la question de savoir
comment l'enfant a été conçu puisqu'au
fond c'est un peu le problème mais je
pense que le choix
la vraie question c'est de savoir si on
peut traiter de cette question dans un
dispositif dans une loi sur le mariage
ou dans un texte sur la filiation ou sur
lie alors vos traces et pas titre
personnel et en tant que ministre
est-ce qu'on peut le faire dans ce texte
là où est ce qu'il faudra un autre texte
en mai le gouvernement avait pas choisi
de le mettre dans ce dom dans ce texte
là qu'est ce que vous ce nouveau texte
c'est la réponse que la discussion qui a
lieu aujourd'hui il n'y a pas eu de
décision de prise mais vous savez il
faut aussi c'est un peu dommage en
france on peut pas débattre y compris
avec l'opposition de ces questions si on
regarde ce qu'avait dit monsieur
leonetti
quand la question s'est posée sur les
lois bioéthiques il avait répondu non on
veut pas en parler dans les lois
bioéthiques il faut que ce soit traité
dans une loi sur la famille vous
répondre car nous répond le contraire
dans le choix qu'il faut ce bien se
mettre d'accord sur quelques questions
se posent et puis s'il ya une sauce ya
des solutions le gouvernement est prêt
naturellement à en débattre avec sa
majorité et le débat sur la gestation
pour autrui est ce qu'il faut le mettre
aussi dans une autre dans une autre loi
comme les fermes il est fermé totalement
fermés
la réponse est non la pma c'est quelque
chose qui existe ya pas de débat sur la
procréation médicale assistée
on sait que ça existe aujourd'hui pour
les couples hétérosexuels donc il n'y a
pas de débat dans la société pour savoir
si on peut le faire ou pas le faire là
c'est qui peut en bénéficier la gpa
c'est à dire la gestation pour autrui et
merci à tous c'est une mère porteuse
c'est non si je résume vos propos si on
peut essayer de les résumer la vidéo
qu'on soit très très clair
pour l'instant il ya un texte en tout
cas un amendement qui sera proposée sur
un texte à l'assemblée nationale
si les députés ne trouve pas d'accord or
11 janvier c'est la date butoir est ce
que vous serez à même le gouvernement de
proposer un autre texte avec la pma à
l'intérieur ou pas le choix le choix de
déposer un amendement ou pas résulte de
l'initiative du groupe socialiste et
manuellement
non mais je dire le gouvernement c'est
le gouvernement au départ n'a pas fait
de texte avec la pma s'il ya une
initiative parlementaire il a dit dans
quel cadre et dans quel cadre très
strict il s'en remettrait à la sagesse
du parlement peut pas y avoir deux
discours plus précis que ça alors je
vous cliquez sur un petit sondage comme
7% c'est un sondage ifop paru ce matin
le figaro
7 % des français considèrent ce texte
comme prioritaires 62% sur la réduction
de la dette
ça vous inspire quoi ça m'inspire
effectivement c'est pour ça que le
gouvernement ne consacre pas son
activité uniquement aux questions
sociétales et que le bilan de la session
qui se termine il est à 90% sur des
sujets économiques et sociaux c'est à
dire ceux qui arrivent en tête des
préoccupations des français bat la
liaison et toutes faites vous allez nous
parler de ce bilan de tout ce que vous
allez lois qui ont été votées à
l'assemblée nationale au sénat bien
évidemment le travail parlementaire n'a
pas chômé il ya douze projets de lois
trois propositions de lois traités
budgétaire l'emploi d'avenir le logement
social de terroristes j'en oublie
sûrement
mais vous avez connu aussi quelques
couacs ici au scénario et syntec cinq
textes qui ne sont pas passés par une
majorité de gauche
oui je conteste complètement la
qualificative de couacs
c'est une situation non c'est une si je
ne contesterai jusqu'au bout il n'a
d'ailleurs aucune possibilité de
justifier à passer à gauche il ya de
quoi quand un groupe qui n'est pas au
gouvernement ne respecte pas la
solidarité gouvernementale le groupe
communiste n'a aucun engagement
vis-à-vis du gouvernement il fait partie
de la gauche nous discutons avec eux il
ya des textes on peut citer ceux qui ne
votent pas mais vous pouvez aussi citer
la banque publique d'investissement qui
a été votée ici aussi au sénat avec avec
le coche contre toute la droite
donc c'est une situation particulière
mais il n'y a aucune rupture
de la solidarité gouvernementale puisque
ils ont choisi et c'est respectable de
ne pas faire partie du gouvernement donc
je conteste complètement la formule du
couac c'est une réalité politique et
nous nous le vivons sereinement pas de
quoi qu'est ce qui s'est passé il ya
deux jours sur le week-end dernier sur
le budget avec les verts qui ont
notamment enlevé le plan compétitivité
qui ont supprimer par amendement la tva
dans ce plan compétitivité ça ce par
quoi que ça non c'est pas un quad accord
parce qu'il sait plus comment lorsque si
vous voulez aller jusqu'au bout fois ce
moment là faire référence au vote final
ce qui s'est passé sont votées mais ont
voté un un projet de loi finalement qui
a été nettoyée qualité de ce qu'ils ne
voulaient pas pas du tout je pense que
vous vous faites une erreur nous avons
fait un vote bloqué en réintégrant ce
qu'ils avaient ce sur quoi il s'était
prononcé on a posé la question de
confiance et ils ont été au rendez vous
c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné même
s'il ya des désaccords
franchement c'est normal il ya plusieurs
partenaires mais quand il ya des
désaccords et qu'il y à un texte
notamment à vocation budgétaire qui
engage la solidarité gouvernementale
eh bien ils l'ont votée il ya eu aucun
couac est ce que vous avez peut-être
cette impression des sénateurs en tout
cas qui nous parle aujourd'hui nous
disent qu'ils ont l'impression que le
gouvernement passe un petit peu outre
l'avis du sénat parce que les
communistes votre compte certains textes
référents comme notamment le budget on
se dit finalement ils ont ils sont
majoritaires à l'assemblée alors que ces
drames il passe un petit peu on le met
un petit peu de côté honnêtement si le
sénat a été privé de débattre notamment
des missions budgétaires qui était un
moment important pour lui le
gouvernement n'est strictement pour rien
il ya eu une addition de voix et si
notamment la droite du sénat ne voulais
pas que ça se passe eh bien elle n'avait
qu'à laisser passer la première partie
on aurait eu un débat normal au sénat
d'ailleurs elle a essayé de se racheter
par une opération assez compliqué en
deuxième partie de loi de finances qui
est totalement incohérent et
incompréhensible du coup le groupe
socialiste a fait blocage est à la
manoeuvre est le débat manoeuvre
grossière
réponse aussi de procédure mais
franchement le sénat pouvait discuter et
ce qu'il faut c'est de dire que le
gouvernement aujourd'hui fait l'impasse
sur le scénar beaucoup des textes que
vous avez cités ont été enrichis du
débat sénatorial est la position du
gouvernement c'est que nous sommes très
attachés au bicamérisme et que le sénat
a tout son rôle à jouer et sur les
textes qui vont venir en janvier
notamment si vous formuler un voeu pour
2013 c'est lequel en tout cas peut-être
pour le groupe communiste j'espère qu'il
change un petit peu d'avis c'est le
moment des bonnes résolutions 2013 si
c'est pas c'est pas un voeu un souhait
c'est certain mais c'est un travail
politique et donc nous ne changerons pas
de position nous débattrons avec eux sur
tous les textes pour essayer de voir si
on peut parvenir à un accord nous ne se
détourneront pas de cette ligne de
conduite vis-à-vis du bon communiste
on avance un petit peu sur les questions
d'actualité il de questions d'actu et
est importante aussi pointé spectateurs
ce sont les retraites
vous avez sûrement vu l'analyse du corps
le conseil d'orientation des retraites
qui parle d'un déficit de près de 25
milliards d'euros à l'objectif 2020
est-ce qu'il est trop pessimiste ce
conseil d'orientation des retraites
selon vous alors il est pas trop
pessimiste vous savez que ces chiffres
seront précisées dans un nouveau rapport
début début janvier donc on va
l'attendre il ya des processus de
consultation mais il faut faire deux
observations la première c'est que ce
qui nous avait dit que l'affairé était
réglée ils nous ont menti ou dans tous
les cas ils se sont trompés la réforme
était pas bonne en même temps je veux
nuancer cette appréciation et on le
verra c'est pour ça qu'il faut avoir le
détail du du corps ça dépend de la
situation de la croissance et des
projections vous savez c'est extrêmement
extrêmement du chômage ne sera pas
suffisante
ça dépend de la croissance à des pans de
baisse du chômage et en même temps pour
être précis par rapport à ce qu'ils
disent
il ya une évolution c'est à dire qu'il
ya une dizaine d'années extrêmement
difficile et ensuite parce que la
situation de la démographique de la
france sera différente chacun comprend
bien ce qu'on appelle le le papy boom
c'est à dire des générations qui sont
très nombreuses aujourd'hui qu'ils le
seront moins dans 15 ans et c'est en
fonction de l'ensemble de ses résultats
qu'on fera une nouvelle réforme est
nécessaire et très concrètement ce corps
ce conseil d'orientation des retraites
dit tout simplement qu'il faudra partir
à la retraite plus tard que ce qui est
déjà le cas aujourd'hui 62 ans fera
peut-être 63 ans est un peu plus et
éventuellement aussi baisser les
pensions sinon on s'en sortira pas
quelque chose que vous envisagez le
corps va donner toutes les solutions à
celle là il faut rajouter d'autres il ya
la hausse des cotisations par exemple
c'est quelque chose qui est là on saura
qui aura des pistes le 22 janvier
prochain il y aura il y aura une période
de négociation et je comprends votre
impatience mais nous n'allons pas mettre
de côté les partenaires sociaux on a dit
qu'on le ferait comme ça il y aura une
réforme et cette réforme elle aura pour
objectif principal nous préserver le
pouvoir d'achat des retraites et surtout
d'avoir un système qui est équilibré à
long terme ce que n'a pas fait la
dernière réforme mais si je vous écoute
bien la baisse des cotisations c'est
quelque chose qu'on pourrait imaginer
non pas la baisse des cotisations
l'augmentation location par an je le
rajoute je le rajoute est pour être
complet à l'ensemble des pistes que vous
avez évoquées pour dire qu'il n'ya pas
que la piste de l'allongement n'y a pas
que la piste de la diminution des
pensions il ya aussi celle de
l'augmentation des retraites et il peut
y avoir un mix de tout ça donc il y aura
une réponse mais pour l'instant
n'essayez pas d'avancée des réponses qui
n'existent pas watelet les négociations
palau un petit peu aussi de ce cas où
tout le monde a parlé évidemment celui
de gérard depardieu
vous aviez estimé que 85 % d'impôt soit
sur le revenu ou sur le patrimoine
c'était impossible à payer si vous
reprenez ce que j'ai dit est en train de
beaucoup d'erreurs de la part de vos
confrères
j'ai dit que quatre monsieur depardieu
écrit qu'ils la paient 85 % d'impôt sur
le revenu dit que c'est vrai 85 %
d'impôt sur le revenu auquel j'ai livé
c'est clair impossible si vous êtes si
vous ajoutez pour dire que je me trompe
ou un certain nombre de vos confrères
disent ah oui mais il paye 80% six ans
mais en plus impôt sur la fortune
alors si vous ajoutez l'impôt sur la
fortune vous mélangez un impôt sur le
patrimoine et vous vous trouvez dans une
situation singulière c'est d'ailleurs ce
raisonnement là et justifier le chèque à
madame bettencourt
donc moi j'ai parlé d'impôt sur le
revenu parce que monsieur depardieu
avait parlé d' impôt sur le revenu et je
ne comprends pas que tout le monde
maintenant dit non mais c'est si ça
concerne l ensemble ses mots à lui en ce
sens et ma réponse aussi est tout
simplement il ya aussi peut-être une
autre question qui est en train de
surgir c est ce que trop d'impôt tué
l'impôt
car pour 2012 on aura battu des records
notamment sur le paiement de liesse f
qu'on peut pas tenir deux discours celui
de dire il faut réduire la dette et pour
réduire la dette il faut diminuer les
dépenses et augmenter les recettes c'est
exactement ce que nous faisons c'est un
langage de vérité pour le redressement
de la france
merci beaucoup à la vie d'alice on va
vous laisser bien sûr regagné
l'hémicycle pour les questions
d'actualité vous le voyez sur ces images
le président de séance est en train de
gagner l'hémicycle à son tour
nous allons beaucoup parler évidemment
des questions aujourd'hui des questions
d'environnement des questions
économiques très importantes des
questions de société
nous verrons tout ça dans on refait la
séance mais tout de suite place aux
questions d'actualité
bonne séance à tout à l'heure sur public
sénat
la séance est ouverte le compte-rendu
analytique de la précédente séance a été
distribué il n'ya pas d'observation le
procès verbal est adoptée sous les
réserves d'usagé
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues l'ordre du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
je rappelle que l'auteur de la question
de même que là où le ministre pour sa
réponse disposent chacun de deux minutes
trente
la parole est à monsieur jean vincent
placé pour le groupe écologiste
merci de votre soutien mais chaque col
legno en effet j'ai retrouvé une partie
de mes moyens
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
monsieur le ministre en charge du
développement cher pascal canfin la
conférence de doha à défaut d'avoir
réalisé un accord universel ambitieux a
mis en valeur l'urgence de progresser
vers la réduction des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre en effet les rapports
scientifiques confirment la réalité du
réchauffement climatique et ses
conséquences désastreuses tant pour la
biodiversité que pour l'homme
l'augmentation globale des températures
entraîne la fonte de nombreux glaciers y
compris chez nous dans les alpes par
exemple ce phénomène accroît également
les problématiques agricoles de
ressources en eau douce de disparition
d'espèces pour l'homme
les impacts sont graves le risque
d'inondations côtières est décuplée
tandis que certaines maladies se
propagent notamment via les moustiques
ou les pollens certaines régions du
monde sont particulièrement vulnérables
et ne dispose pas des moyens nécessaires
pour y faire face les pays du sud
représente en particulier un point
central de la problématique du
réchauffement climatique
d'une part la lutte contre les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre doit se faire
avec tout le monde
d'autre part pour que les accords
fonctionne et que les pays les plus
riches acceptent des règles
contraignantes
il faut éviter la concurrence
internationale qui risquerait de les
pénaliser à cause leurs efforts en
faveur de la protection de
l'environnement
nous avons donc un intérêt économique à
ce que les pays du sud participent à
l'action pour le climat
enfin les pays du nord ont également une
obligation à agir au nom de leur
responsabilité historique dans le
changement climatique à la suite du
terrible typhon bofa les philippines ont
lancé un appel à tous les dirigeants
pour agir contre le réchauffement
climatique les pays du sud réclament aux
pays développés des financements pour
faire face aux effets du réchauffement
le président la république françois
hollande a proposé que la france
accueille la course
en de l'onu sur le climat en 2015 lors
de la conférence environnemental à paris
le secrétaire général des nations unies
ban ki moon a quant à lui proposé qu'un
sommet près c'est le grand rendez vous
de 2015
le groupe écologiste au sénat se réjouit
de ces annonces mais se pose la question
la france sera t elle prête si la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique n'a
pas de valeur elle a un coût et je
conclus par ma question monsieur le
président je savais que j'étais
impatient mais chaque pôle d'aig
monsieur le ministre quel financement la
france mobilise tel pour la lutte contre
le changement climatique
actuellement notamment en faveur des
pays du sud comment atteindre les fameux
100 milliards de dollars par an de
financements protiva en 2020
conformément aux engagements de
copenhague
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur pascal canfin ministre chargé
du développement
monsieur le président monsieur sénateur
jean vincent placé
vous m'interrogez sur les financements
en faveur du climat mobilisés par la
france notamment en faveur des pays du
sud effectivement j'étais à doha au
sommet sur le climat avec laurent fabius
ministre des affaires étrangères et
delphine batho ministre de l'écologie du
développement durable et de l'énergie et
nous avons pris une part active à ces
négociations la france était le pays le
plus représenté au niveau ministériel et
nous avions également une délégation de
parlementaires dont un sénateur que je
tiens particulièrement à saluer monsieur
ronan dantec
lors de cette négociation je me suis
plus particulièrement impliqué sur les
questions financières ou j'ai représenté
l'union européenne avec mon collègue
britannique et j'ai vu à quel point
évidemment ces sujets étaient centraux
dans la capacité ou l'incapacité à
trouver un accord international sur le
climat
la france a tenu les engagements qu'elle
avait pris à copenhague ont ce qu'on
appelle les financements précoces et
nous avons mobilisé 1,2 milliard d'euros
sur trois ans et je tiens à souligner
que celle-ci cet engagement a été tenu
en 2010 2011 et 2012 c'est bien par
l'effort du précédent gouvernement et je
tenais à le saluer au delà des
engagements passés nous avons évidemment
une responsabilité sur les engagements
futurs et notre responsabilité c'est
d'aller bien évidemment au delà de ce
qui a été déjà été fait nous avons
décidé d'affecter en priorité
6 milliards d'euros dans le secteur des
énergies avec comme priorité les
énergies renouvelables et l'efficacité
énergétique
ce choix n'était pas fait auparavant ce
sont des financements qui vont
contribuer à la lutte contre le
changement climatique
nous avons décidé d'affecter 10 % la
taxe sur les transactions financières
françaises à au développement et la
moitié de ces 10 % viendront abonder ce
qu'on appelle le fonds vert qui a été
décidée à copenhague et donc nous allons
augmenter notre financement climat par
ailleurs la france et vous le savez le
pays le plus actif dans la négociation
avec ses dix partenaires européens pour
mettre en place une taxe européenne sur
les transactions financières et en
affecter une partie au développement
dont une partie sera aussi affecté à la
mobilisation en matière de financements
climat donc sur cet agenda international
la france non seulement à respecter ses
engagements passés
mais aujourd'hui elle est en pointe vous
pouvez compter sur nous mais nous avons
aussi besoin de la mobilisation de
l'ensemble des parlementaires pour que
l'accord de 2015 à paris soit un succès
oui
la parole est à madame laurence cohen
pour le groupe communiste républicain et
citoyen monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues depuis le 93 et la mise en
oeuvre du système européen des banques
centrales
l'indépendance de la bogue de la banque
de france a été jugée indispensable ce
qui est extrêmement important dans le
cas d'une construction européenne qui
dois-je le rappeler a été rejetée par
nos concitoyens lors du référendum de
2005 la banque de france est certes
indépendante car elle ne peut faire
fonctionner la planche à billets pour
répondre aux liquidités aux besoins de
liquidités de l'état mais elle est aussi
une institution dont le capital
appartient à l'état qui peut la chargée
de mission d'intérêt général
ceci du fait de dispositions du code
monétaire et financier le président
landes a déclaré à plusieurs reprises
que son adversaire principal était le
monde de la finance ce qui a notamment
permis le rassemblement du 6 mai cette
prise de position pour notre part au
niveau du groupe crc nous la partageons
nous la portons avec force et
détermination
aussi semble-t-il totalement
incompréhensible dans ce climat que le
gouvernement de la banque de france
monsieur noyer entend réduire de manière
drastique les effectifs de cette banque
qui rappelons le est un service public
et quand je dis réduction c'est près de
2000 postes supprimés 2000 postes qui
vont manquer dans les succursales
déconcentré rendant notamment plus
difficile le traitement des dossiers de
surendettement
l'une des missions d'intérêt général
confiée à la banque avec une
satisfaction globalement partagées 2000
postes qui vont manquer pour affiner
l'action de la banque publique
d'investissement alors même que la
qualité de l'information économique dont
dispose la banque de france est une
condition nécessaire à l'action du
nouvel établissement 2000 postes alors
même que les missions essentielles de
sécurité des moyens de paiement de
connaissance de l'activité de l'ensemble
des acteurs financiers comme des milieux
économiques de la banque de france
justifie pleinement que l'institution
dispose des effectifs nécessaires 2000
postes alors même que se posent de plus
en plus la question de la qualité de la
monnaie européenne
que la bce sans vouloir confier à des
entreprises sous-traitantes 2000 postes
qui s'ajoutent au plan de licenciement
qui assombrissent l'avenir de milliers
de femmes et d'hommes de leur famille
aux quatre coins de france
que comptez vous faire monsieur le
ministre à l'égard du plan noyer de
déstructuration de la banque de france
allez vous convoquer une table ronde
avec les personnels dont nous soutenons
la lutte et l'ensemble des parties
prenantes
il est temps que cette cette logique
tueuse d'emplois qui de florange et la
reid à la rue de la banque
d'aulnay-sous-bois petite couronne de
sanofi aux 3 suisses méprise l'intérêt
général pour notre part nous pensons que
les salariés de toutes ces entreprises
et de bien d'autres ont besoin d'un
bouclier législatif telle une loi qui
interdise les suppressions d'emplois
avisé boursière et qui donne des droits
et des pouvoirs nouveaux salariés
nous y sommes prêts qu'en pensez vous
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur pierre
moscovite chip ministre de l'économie et
des finances monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs 17 heures madame
la sénatrice laurence cohen je veux
d'abord dire toute l'ascension
évidemment vous en doutez que je porte
au sujet que vous évoquez parce que nous
avons le souci à la fois de moderniser
l'action publique celle de ces
opérateurs et en même temps de préserver
la qualité du service public l'emploi et
la couverture géographique de ses
services publics c'est le cas de la
banque de france je ne vais pas
polémiquer avec vous pour savoir ce qui
a été rejeté en 2005 je ne crois pas que
ce soit la construction européenne c'est
un texte européen
certes important mais la construction
européenne reste tout de même une donnée
à laquelle nous sommes profondément
attachés
la banque de france pour ce contexte
doit faire face c'est un fait
une mutation profonde importante de ces
conditions d'exercice dans le cadre de
ses missions et c'est la poussée engager
une réflexion sur l'optimisation de son
organisation et comme vous l'avez dit le
gouverneur a présenté le 21 septembre
dernier un plan de réorganisation qui
fait l'objet actuellement d'une
consultation à la fois des personnels et
des acteurs locaux j'ai moi même reçu
les syndicats de la banque de france
à montbéliard dont je suis l'élu la
banque de france vous devez soigner
c'est une autorité indépendante en même
temps l'état et son actionnaire il est
attentif à ses missions d'intérêt
général et je suis évidemment attentif
la conduite de ce plan et six au total
je le soutiens avec cette attention avec
les discussions qu'il faut me laisser
pour quatre raisons d'abord parce que ce
plan garantit le maintien d'une
couverture géographique importante
notamment par la présence d'une
succursale de la banque de france chaque
département voire plus là où les
conditions économiques et géographiques
le justifie ainsi la banque de france va
maintenir des bureaux d'accueil
d'information dont les villes où la
banque reçoit plus de mille visiteurs
par an ces cinq par jour
vous êtes sénatrice du val de marne les
bureaux d'accueil de vincennes
d'ivry-sur-seine de créteil seront
conservés par exemple deuxième sujet le
plan permet une optimisation la gestion
des activités qui ne nécessite pas un
contact avec le public mais je vais vous
assurer que par exemple tout ce qui va
dans le sens du traitement des
surendettés du surendettement sera bien
sûr maintenu et défendu troisièmement le
plan repose sur il faut le dire de
manière réaliste à un calendrier quand
même très très progressif puisqu'il n'y
aura aucune fermeture d'unités de
tertiaire avant 2016 lors ce qui
concerne l'activité fiduciaire
ça sera aussi de manière progressive en
lien avec la livraison de nouveaux
centres fiduciaire enfin et surtout non
je ne peux pas accepter comme ça d'être
qualifié de tueur d'emplois
ce n'est pas ce que nous souhaitons
faire il ya un plan de sauvegarde de
l'emploi qui est prévu pour les
pardonnez moi il le chiffre est
important
227 agents qui sont concernés par les
fermeture de caisses et compte tenu des
départs en retraite se sont seulement
175 agents qui seront concernés par les
reclassements géographique ou
fonctionnelle et la banque prévoit déjà
les formations les offres des mutations
qui permettront d'anticiper dans les
meilleures conditions cette mobilité
donc in fine et ce plan je veux le dire
ici se fera sans aucun licenciement vous
pouvez être certain que les
consultations les concertations seront
menées et qui évidemment j'y serai très
attentif en tant que représentant de
l'état actionnaire
la parole est à monsieur jean michel
baylet pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
merci monsieur le président
hier à l'initiative des radicaux et du
président du rds jacques mézard de
nombreux sénateurs appartenant
d'ailleurs à différents nos politiques
parmi lesquels le présent du sénat
lui-même qui s'est rallié à notre
initiative ont interpellé en urgence le
premier ministre pour dénoncer les
modifications des critères de
répartition des fonds département des
fonds départementaux de péréquation
modification introduite à l'assemblée
nationale dans des conditions que nous
jugeons inacceptable tant sur le fond
que sur la forme de cette situation
intolérable en effet quelques députés
ont subrepticement introduit par voie
d'amendement de nouveaux critères de
répartition de ces aides financières et
surf et ne favorise de favoriser
particulièrement leur collectivité au
détriment des départements les plus en
difficulté
chers collègues de l'opposition étant
donné la manière dont vous avez traité
les collectivités je vous encourage
avantage le tranquillité
et notamment parmi ces collectivités
bien naturellement les plus fragiles
d'entre elles c'est à dire les
départements ruraux
vous conviendrez madame le ministre
qu'il s'agit d'une curieuse conception
de la péréquation financière et de la
justice fiscale
car ces nouveaux critères votée par
l'assemblée nationale dans le projet de
haute finance profite surtout aux
départements les plus riches les mieux
dotées et les plus peuplées au détriment
des autres les deux tiers soit dit en
passant
dans la plupart connaissent déjà des
difficultés financières immense pour
faire face aux dépenses du quotidien aux
dépenses à caractère social
ces réponses tellement nécessaire
aujourd'hui pour protéger nos
concitoyens de la crise madame le
ministre ce n'est pas notre conception
l'égalité territoire et nous sommes
derrière que ce n'est ni la vôtre
ni celle du printemps la république car
une telle évolution est manifestement en
contradiction avec les engagements que
furent les nôtres à vous à nous durant
la campagne électorale
elle est également incompatible avec la
création d'un ministère de l'égalité des
territoires
faut-il rappeler à nouveau dans cette
enceinte où on s'intéresse en priorité
aux territoires que la péréquation
constitue la base de la justice
territoriale el simane le ministre alors
que la procédure parlementaire ne perde
mais malheureusement plus heureux de
revenir sur ces mesures injustes puisque
le budget a été adopté définitivement ce
matin par le député donc cru comprendre
nous emmène compris que notre initiative
des vitraux etc auprès du premier
ministre et que celui ci était annulé le
niveau dispositif en question
alors madame la ministre vous pouvez
vous prendre l'engagement formel de vals
une enquête à cela quand et à quelle
occasion
le parlement a dit la possibilité se
prononcer sur ces questions essentielles
pour les territoires que pouvez-vous
enfin dire aux sénateurs et aux élus
locaux pour les assurer du respect des
principes d'équité dans les dispositifs
de péréquation
la parole est à madame marylise
lebranchu ministre de la réforme de
l'état de la décentralisation et de la
fonction publique
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur jean michel baylet alors
escoffier moi même avons animé un débat
complexe riche en échanges sur plusieurs
dispositions destinées à venir à l'appui
des territoires les plus en difficulté
un fonds d'urgence de 170 millions a été
créée par le gouvernement en profite des
départements le gouvernement a entendu
les débats qui existent sur les critères
d'attribution de sommes du fonds
d'urgence
le débat a eu lieu il est important
maintenant de s'atteler à la mise en
place concrète de ce fonds mais ce
ballet vous savez que le gouvernement a
fait beaucoup d'efforts en termes de
péréquation dans ce projet de loi de
finances et que nous rejoignons en
grande partie ce que voudrait dire à
l'instant le fonds de péréquation de la
contribution sur la valeur ajoutée les
entreprises a été mis en place et les
dispositions proposées ont fait l'objet
de travaux dans le cadre du groupe de
travail du comité des finances locales
et le gouvernement a proposé un
dispositif qui était équilibré en
intégrant des critères de charges en
particulier des revenus moyens
dans l'ensemble des dispositifs de
péréquation c'est une volonté forte de
la gauche vous l'avez rappelé d'intégrer
des critères de charles ix des critères
justes pour ajuster la qualification
horizontale entre les territoires
c'est aussi une volonté forte du sénat
puisque cette proposition figurait dans
le rapport de la mission commune
d'information sur la taxe
professionnelle rendu public l'an passé
rapport signé par charles guené et anne
marie escoffier à l'époque pour les
critères de répartition du fonds de
péréquation des droits de mutation à
titre onéreux les fameux dmt au la
logique du gouvernement est la même nous
avons intégré des critères de charge de
aussi de revenus moyens pour renforcer
les effets père équateur les débats à
l'assemblée nationale ont conduit à des
modifications sensibles qui je le
regrette n'ont pas pu être examinés par
votre haute assemblée du fait du rejet
de la première partie
du projet de loi de finances sur ce fond
dmt haut
c'est dommage que nous n'ayons pu a pas
pu avoir ce débat nous n'en serions pas
là
sur ce fond dmt au les premières
simulations ont suscité beaucoup
d'inquiétudes sur les bancs de votre
assemblée
nous avons entendu ces inquiétudes la
nous avons évalué le dispositif dans le
cadre du comité des finances locales
mais comme le premier ministre l'a
indiqué est ici est engagée
solennellement les fonds de péréquation
de la cvae et ddmt au seront réexaminés
aussi vite que possible au cours du
premier semestre 2013
au vu des résultats de simulation dont
vous avez parlé c'est un engagement du
premier ministre il nous reste à trouver
un véhicule législatif mais je voudrais
juste ajouter un mot monsieur jean
michel baylet c'est vrai que vos
arguments sont justes mais c'est vrai
aussi que sur les péréquations telles
qu'elles ont été déterminées dans les
années passées telles qu'elles
continuent nous avons beaucoup de soucis
il fera qu'on se parle aussi de façon
très précise de la péréquation verticale
c'est à dire de plus de justice dans les
dotations du base
je pense que si nous pouvons faire ce
travail nous aurons moins de difficultés
et de bagarres d'amendements conduisant
parfois à des échecs
merci la parole est à monsieur roger
karoutchi pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
ce président chers collègues la question
s'adresser à monsieur le premier
ministre mais c'est un bonheur
madame que ce soit vous qui répondiez
les français comme les parlementaires
sont aujourd'hui touchées frappé par de
grands problèmes
fiscalité sécurité emploi chômage etc de
la part du gouvernement par dont on ne
voit pas en tout cas nous beaucoup
d'évolutions mais en revanche que de
créativité électorale un président de
groupe de notre noble assemblée
appartenant à la majorité présidentielle
nous a annoncé d'ores et déjà le
prochain résultats de l'élection
sénatoriale
en disant que du fait de la réforme il y
aurait quatre sièges de plus pour la
gauche
on nous dit maintenant on nous dit
maintenant on nous dit maintenant que un
certain nombre de présidents de conseils
généraux 10 mai la réforme prévue pour
les élections cantonales défavoriserait
ce président défavoriserait les
territoires ruraux
la réforme prévue pour le sénat au delà
du reste notamment sur la
proportionnelle des favoriserait
également les départements ruraux et
puis on reporte si le conseil
constitutionnel le souhaitent ou la tête
les élections cantonales et régionales
on réforme
le scrutin sénatorial on nous annonce
une réforme du scrutin européen
on nous annonce une réforme avec une
part de proportionnelle pour les
législatives
on nous annonce des réformes sur les
intercommunalités
c'est à dire que en fait nous ne voyons
toujours pas venir de vraies réformes
économiques et sociales fondamentales
pour le pays mais a en revanche la
capacité d'initiative pour conserver le
pouvoir par des réformes électorales est
absolument incontestable
alors madame madame la mairie
madame la ministre nous nous nous
laissons nous laissons nous nous
laissons les choses et nous laissons
ducal du can duquel nos chers collègues
je sais bien que ça vous gêne je sais
que ça vous gêne
mais restez calmes c'est pas bon pour
votre coeur madame la ministre
est-ce qu' il ne serait pas tant de la
part du gouvernement de dire qu'à une
pause sur les réformes de ce genre sur
la réforme électorale
voyons d'abord ce que nous devons faire
au niveau économique et social laisser
les électeurs au travers des systèmes
électoraux qui sont en place et qui
n'ont pas démérité exprimer leur opinion
dans l'avenir en tout cas nous attendons
de la part du gouvernement une
confirmation celle que naturellement
nous n'irons pas vers des réformes
électorales au pas de charge
électorales que le conseil
constitutionnel serait amené à censurer
la parole est à madame marylise
lebranchu
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur ferrucci le projet de loi
actuellement en discussion devant votre
assemblée
je ne relève pas tous les propos que
vous avez dit que vous avez adopté qui a
été adopté hier par votre commission des
loi prévoit en effet de reporter oui
monsieur le président en 2015 les
futures élections départementales et
régionales
je vous rappelle qu'avec l'abrogation du
conseiller territorial
à l'initiative du sénat et avec ici
comme à l'assemblée nationale une très
large majorité
on se retrouvait avec cinq élections en
2014 et trois élections le même jour au
mois de mars
or trois élections le même jour pour
beaucoup de petites communes rurales
c'est impossible à organiser comme vous
le savez 96 % du corps électoral des
élections sénatoriales est aujourd'hui
composé de représentants des seules
communes soit environ 142 milles sur 148
1000 membres du collège électoral
ils seront bien élu en mars 2014
mes conseillers généraux représentent
2,7 pour cent de ce collège est
déconsidéré jeunes aux 1,2 pour cent du
collège c'est donc un nombre très faible
regard du collège électoral sénatorial
je vois que vous êtes toujours partisan
avec optimisme et peut-être experts du
conseiller territorial mais tel n'est
plus le cas
je vous rappelle donc qu en décalant ces
élections qu en décalant ces élections à
2015 le projet de loi ne fait que
s'approcher de la durée normale des
mandats qui est de six ans alors que
l'échéance de mars 2014 monsieur
karoutchi vous vous en souvenez était le
fait du raccourcissement exceptionnel
décidé à l'initiative du gouvernement
précédent qui a raccourci à quatre ans
le mandat des conseillers régionaux élus
en 2010 et à 3 ans celui des conseillers
généraux élus en 2011
c'est donc un retour vers la durée
mandales des mandats que vous devriez
applaudir c'est vous qui aviez organisé
un raccourcissement artificielle qui
permettait une élection en mars 2014
donc avant les élections sénatoriales et
le nouveau calendrier lui est en fait
celui qui correspond à l'ordre normal
des élections
soyez donc rassurés monsieur le sénateur
sur la parfaite régularité
constitutionnel de ce renouvellement et
pour le reste et pour l'avenir
vous savez que le président de la
république a initié des rencontres avec
l'ensemble des partis politiques mais je
voudrais juste vous dire monsieur
karoutchi qu'un mandat de quatre ans
pour les conseillers régionaux un mandat
de trois ans pour les conseillers
généraux sortants
ce n'était pas non plus un fait anodin
ça a été discuté extrêmement rapidement
et je voudrais vous dire que ce
gouvernement s'attache beaucoup à
redresser le pays et que s'il n'y avait
pas eu besoin de redresser le pays
effectivement aux premiers propos aurait
été malvenu
la parole est à monsieur jean boyer pour
le groupe union des démocrates
indépendants
le président mesdames et messieurs du
ministre mes chers collègues des
dernières propositions du conseil
d'orientation des retraites nous
rappelle si besoin était que celle ci
puisse que jamais sont d'actualité les
chiffres sont inquiétants
en effet si le besoin de financement des
comptes trois principaux régimes
atteignait 14 milliards d'euros en 2011
il s'élèvera à 18 8 milliards d'euros en
pour autant est-ce une surprise nue sur
craig nous ne pensons pas puisque nous
l'avons et je le dis sans aucune
prétention puisque j'étais là des
moments et pas à d'autres
nous l'avons toujours dit jean arthuis
qui est devant moi pourrait le confirmer
si tous
les réformes jusqu'ici ce sont basées
exclusivement sur des hypothèses trop
optimistes outre les données de
conjoncture la tendance structurelle est
lourde et les connu c'est la dégradation
du rapport entre les actifs et les
retraités mais c'est aussi chers
collègues vous le savez une augmentation
d'une espérance de vie qui est à la fois
réjouissante et inquiétante
je vous livre dieu t'a givre cinq heures
de plus par jour et par personne
encore une fois que nous l'avons
aujourd'hui une réforme s'impose dans le
ministre jusqu'ici toutes les réformes
des retraites ont été menées par ce que
l'on peut appeler les gouvernements de
droite
si vous ne franchissez pas madame le
ministre comme le président la
république l'a annoncé ce serait donc
une première et nous serons si vous le
souhaitez
là pour vous encourager cependant les
marges de manoeuvre sont très étroites
au système constant trois leviers pour
être est actionné l'augmentation des
cotisations le retarde l'âge d'ouverture
des droits ou la dégradation des
pensions sachant que ces leviers ont
déjà été actionné par les formes par les
réformes intervenues depuis 1993 dans
ces conditions madame le ministre
allez vous vous attaquez au véritable
inégalité qui demeurent entre les
pensionnés notamment contre les
passionnés du service privé et
pensionnés du service public et en vos
yeux et envisagez vous comme moi même et
les membres de mon groupe
udi us et le demandons depuis des années
de mettre enfin en oeuvre une véritable
réforme structurelle remplaçant la
nuitée par le point ou par un système en
comptes notionnels
merci de vos réponses
la parole est à madame marisol touraine
un ministre des affaires sociales et de
la santé
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur vous avez à juste titre relevé
que le rapport du conseil d'orientation
des retraites qui a été mise en
discussion hier fait état de
perspectives financières préoccupante
pour l'avenir de nos régimes de retraite
à cet égard néanmoins je voudrais
souligner que ce rapport nous invite à
distinguer les perspectives à court
terme c'est à dire d'ici la fin de la
décennie et des perspectives à plus long
terme moyen ou long terme au delà de
2030 ou 2040
de ce point de vue le constat pour la
décennie engagé est sans appel pour la
réforme qui avait été mise en place par
le précédent gouvernement cette réforme
je voudrais le rappeler avait pour objet
parfaitement identifiés et assumée de
rétablir l'équilibré de nos régimes de
retraites à horizon 2018
or ce que montre le rapport du conseil
d'orientation des retraites c'est que à
cet horizon là c'est à dire d'ici
quelques années
le déficit des régimes de retraite
devrait être
selon les hypothèses économiques mais de
l'ordre de 20 milliards ce qui signifie
que nous sommes évidemment très loin de
l'équilibré ce qu'ils appellent des
mesures que nous aurions souhaité ne pas
avoir à prendre mais je veux rappeler
d'ailleurs que dans la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale nous
avons d'ores et déjà engagé des mesures
de rétablissement en permettant
d'affecter des ressources nouvelles à
l'ensemble de nos régimes de retraite ou
au fonds de solidarité vieillesse qui
montre que l'esprit de responsabilité a
été au rendez vous pour ce gouvernement
dès les premières semaines de sa prise
de fonction au delà en revanche de cette
échéance
nous avons quelques lueurs ou quelques
perspectives plus positives puisque la
situation démographique dans notre pays
qui est très significativement meilleure
que dans d'autres pays européens en
particulier que chez notre voisin
allemand souvent cité en exemple nous
amène à avoir des perspectives plus
favorables alors vous l'avez indiqué
nous avons besoin d'engager une
réflexion et une concertation le rapport
du conseil d'orientation des retraites
sera suivi d'un second rapport à la fin
du mois de janvier qu'il convient
d'attendre parce que ce second rapport
est au moins aussi important que celui
présenté hier
non c'était c'était un rapport prévu sur
les conditions d'équité que vous avez
évoquées dans nos régimes de retraites
en particulier pour mettre en avant la
question de la pénibilité la retraite
des femmes par rapport à celle des
hommes
et toute une série d'éléments qui
doivent être examinées dans une
perspective de justice lorsque nous
disposerons de l'ensemble de ses
appréciations et de ses projections nous
pourrons engager une concertation avec
les organisations syndicales qui fera
l'objet d' abord de travaux avec dans le
cadre d'un groupe des sages mais je veux
le dire monsieur le sénateur pour le
gouvernement
l'exigence est au moins autant une
exigence de justice qu de responsabilité
nous devons mettre en place une réforme
qui nous permette à la fois de garantir
l'équilibré financier des comptes est
d'aboutir à une situation de plus grande
justice dans l'esprit de ce que nous
avons fait en adoptant le décret
permettant à ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler jeunes de partir en retraite
dès 60 ans dans le cadre de la
concertation engagée
l'ensemble des perspectives possibles
seront mis sur la table
la parole est à monsieur alain
fauconnier pour le groupe socialiste et
apparentés
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chers collègues le département dans
l'aveyron se trouve confrontée comme
beaucoup d'autres départements en france
ah non remplacement des médecins
généralistes vaste territoire rural à
faible densité démographique l'aveyron a
heureusement une autre particularité
considérer injustement par certains
comme une aberration cinq hôpitaux
généraux dits de proximité avec
l'ensemble des services et monsieur ce
maillage hospitalier a été préservé
après de longues luttes des populations
concernées
cependant tout cela reste extrêmement
fragile
ces hôpitaux sont en effet confrontées à
une démographie médicale désastreuse et
à une situation financière non
maîtrisable a raison de l'application de
la t2a totalement inadapté à ces petites
structures
le président de la république s'est
engagé à l'égalité d'accès aux soins
pour tous nos concitoyens sur l'ensemble
du territoire
ces critères de temps d'accès aux soins
de premier recours ont été mis en place
vous avez pris à bras le corps ce
problème après des années de laxisme et
de laisser faire du précédent
gouvernement
les populations auprès l'espoir et sont
conscientes de la situation
catastrophique dont vous avez hérité il
convient de ne pas les décevoir
vous avez annoncé un pacte territoire
santé comportant une série de mesures
pour le court et le moyen terme
ces mesures passent entre autres par
l'incitation financière à l'installation
en zone rurale plutôt que par la
contrainte
permettez-moi de faire remarquer que de
nombreuses collectivités départements
régions communes intercommunalités se
sont engagés dans cette voie depuis des
années sans grand succès madame la
ministre
il existe encore sur mon territoire des
petits hôpitaux capacités dans le très
court terme de faire face à la carence
de la médecine dite libérale si tenté
que le rhône en donne les moyens
pouvez vous me préciser quel rôle vous
comptez a signé à l'hôpital public dans
cette période et qu'il délicate que nous
connaissons et qui ne peut
malheureusement que saga
et sa mesure exceptionnelle et
ambitieuse votre réponse mais dalmat
ministre est attendu avec impatience par
tous nos concitoyens qui depuis trop
longtemps se sentent délaissés ainsi que
par les élus quotidiennement confrontés
à ces problèmes
je vous remercie madame la ministre
marisol touraine vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur vous avez raison la veyron et
comme d'autres départements confrontés à
un processus qu'il convient maintenant
d'appeler de désertification médicale
mais je voudrais souligner enfin à cet
égard que les territoires ruraux ne sont
pas les seuls concernés et que
contrairement à ce que certains
pourraient être imaginés des territoires
urbains en particulier les
agglomérations des grandes villes sont
également confrontés à la raréfaction
des professionnels de santé à proximité
de la population vous l'avez également
indiqué le gouvernement a souhaité
prendre à bras le corps cette question
car il y va de l'égalité d'accès aux
soins sur le territoire et à l'évidence
nous ne pouvons pas nous satisfaire de
la situation que nous avons trouvé je
voudrais d'un seul chiffre
établir au fond un diagnostic qui doit
nous préoccuper 2 millions de français
en cinq ans se sont retrouvés habitant
dans des territoires désertifier 2
millions de français supplémentaires en
cinq ans si nous ne faisons rien à
l'évidence la dégradation va se
poursuivre j'ai souhaité au nom du
gouvernement présenté un pacte
territoire santé qui comporte trois
grands axes vous avez souligné que le
choix que j'ai portée et de ne pas
recourir à des mesures coercitives quand
je crois que ces mesures seraient
contournée par les professionnels de
santé et que nous ne pouvons pas
attendre pour prendre des dispositions
puisque c'est maintenant que nous sommes
confrontés à l'exigence la plus fort en
revanche vous me permettrez monsieur le
sénateur de vous indiquer que les
mesures d'âge
tensions financières sont très peu
nombreuses dans ce pacte car l'essentiel
ne réside pas là est l'essentiel réside
bien dans la capacité que nous aurons à
proposer des conditions d'exercice
renouvelée aux professionnels qui
souhaitent désormais des rémunérations
forfaitaires un travail en équipe des
liens avec les structures hospitalières
des liens avec la diversité des
professionnels opérant sur un territoire
trois axes dont qui sont liées à la
rénovation des études médicales avec
l'obligation de stage par exemple et des
aides à l'installation un second axe
autour de la rénovation de la pratique
pour encourager les regroupements de
professionnels et valoriser la
rémunération forfaitaire par rapport à
la seule rémunération à l'acte et enfin
des investissements dans les territoires
isolés et à ce titre monsieur le
sénateur je veux vous dire que je
partage pleinement votre conviction que
les hôpitaux de proximité ont un rôle
majeur à jouer car on ne pourrait
comprendre que des professionnels
libéraux s'installent là où la puissance
publique s'en irait
la parole est à monsieur andré reichardt
pour le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire
seul résident là messieurs les ministres
chers collègues le 30 novembre dernier
le conseil constitutionnel a déclaré
inconstitutionnel l'article 100 f et le
troisième alinéa de l'article sans s du
code professionnel local
d'alsace-moselle par cette décision il
abrogeait le dispositif des corporations
d'artisans obligatoire dans les trois
départements de l'ess or celles ci sont
le fondement du droit local de
l'artisanat qui a permis à l'alsace et à
la moselle de doter leur entreprise d'
avantage concurrentiel certain et de
résister bien bien mieux que beaucoup
d'autres au crise économique qu'a connue
notre pays au cours du dernier siècle
pour bien connaître le secteur de
l'artisanat lsa je peux même vous dire
que c'est notamment à son artisanat qui
est comme vous le savez certainement
particulièrement bien qualifiés que
l'alsace doit sa prospérité économique
des dernières décennies
cette décision est donc particulièrement
grave pour l'économie alsacienne au
moment précisément où notre pays est en
recherche de compétitivité
particulièrement de compétitivité hors
coûts la question qui se pose désormais
est celle des mesures qui peuvent être
prises pour pallier à cette décision et
permettre à nos départements de ne pas
perdre le bénéfice de ces magnifiques
outil qui était à leur disposition en
qualité de président de la commission
d'harmonisation du droit local alsacien
mosan j'envisage avec je l'espère la
totalité des parlementaires des trois
départements à la fois au sénat bien sûr
mais à l'assemblée de déposer une
proposition de loi visant à recréer
officiellement des organisations
professionnelles d'artisans de nora
local obligatoire mais sans encourir
bien sûr à nouveau la censure du conseil
constitutionnel
il s'agit ainsi de permettre la
pérennité des outils qui ont fait
jusqu'ici le succès la pérennité de
l'artisanat d'alsace moselle mais en
supprimant du nouveau dispositif les
modalités qui ont frappé l'ancien
d'inconstitutionnalité d'alors que le
commentaire de la décision du conseil
constitutionnel indique que j'ouvre je
cite jouve relégué mais la liberté
d'entreprendre fondée sur l'article 4 de
la
clarations 1789 n'implique pas que
l'existence de corporation soit en
elle-même contraire à cette liberté
la question qui se pose officiellement
est celle du financement de ces futures
organisations
une solution pourrait consister à
établir une imposition dit de toute
nature dont l'article 34 de la
constitution réserve au législateur le
soin de fixer les règles concernant
l'assiette le taux et les modalités de
recouvrement
mais la voie de la redevance pourrait
aussi être utilisé pour financer les
services rendus par ces organisations
ma question est donc la suivante elle
s'adresse à la fois madame la ministre
du commerce de l'artisanat et du
tourisme est également à madame la garde
des sceaux si elle le permet quelles
mesures le gouvernement entend qu il
prendre pour soutenir voire faciliter la
démarche des parlementaires
d'alsace-moselle engagés à cet égard je
vous remercie
la parole est à madame sylvia pinel
ministre l'artisanat du commerce et du
tourisme
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur vous m'interrogez sur les
conséquences de la décision du conseil
constitutionnel qui a en effet supprimé
certaines dispositions de droit local
quant à l'affiliation obligatoire aux
corporations et quant à leurs
cotisations j'étais justement en alsace
en déplacement à strasbourg lorsque
cette décision est tombée j'ai pu très
vite m'entretenir avec les présidents de
corporations le président de la chambre
des métiers de l'artisanat les artisans
locaux qui m'ont fait part de leurs
inquiétudes et qui ont souligné
l'importance des corporations dans ces
régions dans ces territoires en termes
de conseil aujourd'hui et très vite
lorsque j'ai pu après avoir longuement
échangé avec eux j'ai lancé une
évaluation sur les conséquences précises
de cette annulation
en termes d'emplois et de financement de
ces corporations mais je travaille
également à recenser l'ensemble des
dispositions relatives au droit local
d'alsace moselle qui part ultérieurement
on pourrait être remise en cause en cas
d'une saisine une nouvelle saisine du
conseil constitutionnel il s'agit pour
le gouvernement de stabiliser au plus
vite le droit local et de mettre fin à
cette instabilité juridique que les
corporations connaissent mais elle vous
évoquez monsieur le sénateur une
proposition de loi sur laquelle je
souhaite émettre un certain nombre de
réserves
en effet vous revenez aux principes
d'affiliation obligatoires or c'est ce
principe d'obligation que le conseil
constitutionnel a censuré ce n'est pas
simplement le caractère onéreux de la
filiation qui a été remise en cause dans
cette décision le conseil légitime
l'existence des corporations et ne remet
pas en cause leur existence et je suis
convaincu que cette décision doit nous
pousser les élus les corporations les
artisans les chambres de métiers à
travailler à faire des propositions pour
rendre les corporations plus attractive
plus performantes en termes
d'accompagnement des entreprises en
termes de développement économique en
termes de formation des apprentis et
ainsi elles se rendront indispensable
pour les professionnels
une fois que l'évaluation sera terminé
le gouvernement est totalement
déterminée et mobilisée pour aider les
artisans d'alsace moselle
comme nous sommes d'ailleurs déterminé à
soutenir l'artisanat dans ce pays c'est
la raison pour laquelle je présenterai
fin janvier un plan pour l'artisanat
la parole est à monsieur richard yung
pour le groupe socialiste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le problème
de l'évasion fiscale est loin d'être
nouveau et je veux dire que l'ancienne
majorité
le sait pertinemment puisque vous aviez
essayé de faire revenir en france et
c'est à votre crédit si j'ose dire à
votre crédit en votant le bouclier
fiscal
malheureusement en réalité ce bouclier
ils étaient financés par les
contribuables qui eux sont restés en
france et donc c'est un peu moins
louables de ce point de vue là et le
résultat le résultat n'a pas été très
concluant on doit on doit le dire alors
qu'il aurait fallu renforcer les moyens
de lutte contre la fraude fiscale
comme nous le proposons maintenant comme
il est prévu dans le plfr vous avez jugé
préférable de signer un chèque aux plus
nantis qui avait la bonté de revenir à
fait un fait divers récent un échange
d'amabilités de quelques noms d'oiseaux
a défrayé la chronique en début de
semaine mais honnêtement tout ça est peu
de chose un peu ridicule son taux à la
veille de la fin du monde
franchement
demain demain jeter son passeport jeter
son passeport par dessus les moulins
ça ne résout rien et on ne perd même pas
la nationalité française
les sommes qui ont été indiqué si elles
sont avérées relève de toutes façons de
la politique fiscale de monsieur sarkozy
puisque c'était sur les exercices
mais si madame des ego tout à fait tout
à fait tout à fait il fallait que ça
soit ni et l'engagement l'engagement ump
de l'acteur concerné ne doit pas lui
faire attribué à monsieur ayrault ce qui
appartient à monsieur fillon
j'en viens aux questions j'en viens aux
questions première question
nous savons que l'évasion fiscale est
principalement à l'intérieur de l'europe
la cause est connue celle de mme pin
fiscale entre les pays
donc ma question à monsieur le ministre
est la suivante quels sont les plans
pour développer la convergence fiscale
au sein des pays de l'union 2e
deuxième idée deuxième proposition au
sein de ces pays européens trois pays
frontaliers francophone suisse belgique
luxembourg concentre la majorité des cas
c'est donc les conventions fiscales avec
ces pays qu'il faut renégocier c'était
d'ailleurs un des engagements de du
candidat françois hollande devenu
président de la république je
souhaiterais donc savoir monsieur le
ministre quel est le calendrier et
quelles sont les modalités de
renégociation de ces conventions
fiscales la parole est à monsieur jérôme
cahuzac ministre chargé du budget merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur la question que vous abordez
suppose de répondre à trois éléments
d'abord quel est le volume que vous
décrivez et combien de nos concitoyens
des sept-îles de partir pour échapper à
leurs obligations fiscales partir au
demeurant le plus légalement du monde
deuxième question à poser pour quelle
raison des sept-îles de partir enfin
troisièmement c'est la question à
laquelle vous terminez votre propos que
peut faire le
vernement pour éviter ce qui est
objectivement préjudiciable à l'intérêt
national à la première question on peut
répondre de manière fiable à peu près
jusqu'en 2006 car c'est à cette date que
le mythe du budget de l'époque
jean-françois copé supprime le quitus
fiscal qui permettait précisément
d'évaluer ce qu'était le nombre de
départs pour des raisons fiscales
et il est vrai que parmi les 2,5
millions de nos compatriotes qui sont
expatriés l'écrasante majorité sinon
tous sont partis pour des raisons
professionnelles soit que le travail
qu'ils effectuent nécessite la présence
à l'étranger soit que l'absence de
travail trouvait à l'intérieur de nos
frontières les et contrat à s'expatrier
chacun s'accordera que les deux raisons
ne sont pas équivalentes mais existent
en terme de cause ce que l'on constate
par exemple c'est qu'après 1996 et
l'instauration par le gouvernement juppé
du plafonnement du plafonnement
on a assisté un départ important de
certains de nos compatriotes qui n'ayant
plus l'impôt sur la fortune plafonné au
regard de leurs revenus estimé que ce
qu'ils avaient à acquitter au regard des
dispositions prises par le gouvernement
juppé est votée par la majorité rpr udf
de l'époque ne leur permettaient plus de
rester dans notre pays al'inverse on a
pu constater entre 2002 et 2006 avec une
politique fiscale beaucoup plus
accommodantes qu'en vérité les choses
étaient identiques car entre 2003 et
2006 le nombre d'expatriés fiscaux a été
multiplié par 2,5 et donc deux causes
différentes semble produire le même
effet peut-être peut-on progresser dans
l'analyse en étudiant ce qui s'est passé
après l'instauration du bouclier fiscal
dont je rappelle qu'il avait notamment
provocation d'empêcher des expatriations
et de favoriser des impatriés à sion en
vérité pendant toutes ces années là le
solde fait à peu près le même et le
nombre d'expatriés fiscaux est évalué
par les services du ministère du budget
à 750 à 850 et ce quelles qu'aient été
les modalités bouclier fiscal villepin
au bouclier fiscal
sarkozy est donc imputer à la salle
fiscalité la responsabilité de ces
expatriation pour des raisons fiscales
me semble un tout petit peu juste dans
le raisonnement pour autant et vous avez
raison il faut réagir le président de la
république vous l'avez rappelé a suggéré
que les conditions fiscales soit revue
je crois en effet que c'est la seule
façon d'éviter ce type d'expatriation
ou plus exactement d'éviter que ceux qui
décident de vivre en dehors de nos
frontières s'exonère par là même des
obligations fiscales que ces personnes
ont à l'égard de leur pays dans lequel
elles sont nées dans lequel elles ont
grandi ils ont été éduqués former le
plus souvent où elles ont rencontré la
prospérité sinon la fortune bref un pays
auquel elles doivent beaucoup
et donc tu es long terme semble-t-il de
s'exonérer des charges que celui-ci leur
demande d'acquitter afin d'être
redressées voilà la piste me semble-t-il
qu'il faut suivre mais cessons d'imputer
aux seules raisons fiscales
les raisons de départ car l'on voit dans
notre histoire contemporaine que des
raisons adverse produite en vérité les
mêmes effets incontestablement pour
certains de nos compatriotes
il y aura toujours des raisons de partir
car il estime toujours qu'il payent trop
d'impôts
la parole est à madame christiane
kammermann pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre charles collègues la crise
syrienne et dans son 21e mois le pays
est complètement dévastée par la
répression sanglante des insurgés qui a
fait plus de 40 mille morts et un nombre
incalculable de blessés disparus
prisonniers est essentiellement des
civils
la brûler dit la brutalité de la
répression du régime syrien a nourri le
radicalisme religieux des insurgés or la
syrie est la clé de voûte du
moyen-orient
si elle se désagrège cela pourrait
déstabiliser toute la zone
en remettant ses frontières en question
400000 syriens sont réfugiés dont plus
de 100 milles au liban ce qui constitue
une charge de plus en plus lourdes pour
les pays d'accueil des efforts
diplomatiques sont déployés pour venir
en aide aux populations syrienne
toutefois le conseil de sécurité de
l'onu n'a pas pris de résolution à
raison du veto de la chine et de la
russie
l'action de monsieur lakhdar brahimi le
médiateur international de l'onu et de
la ligue arabe n'a pas donné le résultat
escompté
la seule note d'espoir et man
de la conférence de doha créé il y à un
mois au qatar par plus de 100 pays et
organisations dont l'intitulé conditions
nationale syrienne incarne la
responsabilité diplomatique du peuple
syrien
la réunion de marrakech du 12 décembre
et dans le prolongement de l'engagement
de la communauté internationale en
faveur de cette coalition
dans ce contexte de crise internationale
aiguë monsieur le ministre
voici mes interrogations comment la
france voit tel la transition la
transition politique
le départ de bachar el-assad et la mise
en place d'un nouveau régime politique
en syrie selon vous une transition
négociée est envisageable
qu'est ce que la france a engagé comme
efforts de soutien aux populations
civiles dans les zones libérées
le 11 novembre la conférence de doha a
permis la création d'une coalition de
l'opposition syrienne considérée comme
représentant légitime du peuple syrien
comment la france peut-elle aider cette
coalition à se structurer
pourra-t-elle la reconnaître comme le
seul représentant du peuple syrien
comme le gouvernement légitime de la
syrie comment voyez-vous les
répercussions des troubles dans les
semaines à venir sur la situation au
liban
la sécurité du liban n'est-elle pas de
plus en plus menacé le vote bella ne
risque-t-il pas de jouer la
déstabilisation du liban
qu'est ce que la france est prête à
faire notamment dans les pays voisins
si la situation continue à se dégrader
pour protéger ou évacuer nos
compatriotes
la france maintient at elle sa position
par rapport à l'embargo sur les armes
je vous remercie
la parole est à monsieur bernard
cazeneuve ministre chargé des affaires
européennes
merci beaucoup mais la destinatrice pour
votre question qui montre l'ensemble des
défis auxquels
communauté internationale se trouve
confronté en syrie où se joue un drame
d'abord humanitaire vous l'avez rappelé
vous même dans votre question près de
40000 syriens sont morts dans des
conditions parfois d'une extrême
atrocités parce qu'un régime a décidé de
martyriser son peuple pour se maintenir
au pouvoir
40000 syriens sont morts mais ce sont
aussi 500000 syriens qui se sont trouvés
déplacer dans des conditions d'une très
grande précarité et moment où nous
parlons il ya un risque d'exposition à
des drames humanitaires d'une population
qui est comprise entre 2 millions et 4
millions de syriens
c'est dire l'ampleur de la difficulté
humanitaire à laquelle on se trouve
confronté dans ce pays et dans cette
région mais malgré cela il ya
aujourd'hui des raisons d'espérer
d'espérer avec prudence mais d'espérer
d'abord la situation militaire s'est
considérablement modifié pour des
raisons qui tiennent au fait que la
coalition nationale syrienne s'est dotée
de moyens militaires désormais
coordonnées par un chef d'état major qui
conduit les opérations
avec une efficacité qui a conduit les
troupes de la coalition nationale
syrienne aller jusqu'aux portes de damas
avec une pression très forte exercée
militairement par ses troupes sur le
gouvernement de bachar al assad à tel
point que un certain nombre de pays qui
soutenaient régime de bachar al assad et
je pense notamment à la russie commence
à considérer que son départ du pouvoir
en raison de la pression militaire et
diplomatique qui s'exercent sur lui
pourraient devenir demain inéluctable et
cette situation militaire est de nature
à permettre un approfondissement des
discussions et des échanges
diplomatiques à une augmentation des
pressions qui s'exercent sur le régime
de manière à pouvoir faire en sorte
comme nous le souhaitons depuis
longtemps il quitte le pouvoir
bien entendu cela ne pourra pas se faire
et vous avez raison de le dire en ces
termes si nous n'utilisons pas les
initiatives pour faire en sorte que
cette pression devienne insupportable
qu'elle oblige
l'actuel pouvoir à partir c'est ce que
nous faisons
nous l'avons fait en étant les premiers
à décider de la mise en place d'une aide
humanitaire pour les conseils civile
révolutionnaire nous le faisons en ayant
été les premiers à reconnaître à avoir
reconnu la coalition nationale syrienne
vous interrogé sur le fait de savoir si
nous allions la reconnaître comme un
gouvernement alternatif légitime c'est
déjà fait nous avons été le premier à le
faire nous avons voulu entraîner dans
notre sillage des pays de l'union
européenne et nous avons commencé à le
faire avec succès et la conférence des
amis du peuple syrien à laquelle vous
faisait référence août à leur a permis
un très grand nombre de pays dont les
états unis
à quelques heures de l'ouverture de
cette réunion à reconnaître à leur tour
la coalition nationale syrienne et ne
nous considérons que dès lors que cette
coalition s'est rassemblée qu'elle se
doter d'un leadership fort cela signifie
que nous sommes sur le bon chemin il
faut donc maintenir cette pression
continue a été une manie terme en
multiplie les initiatives politiques
pour que les pays qui hésitent encore à
nous rejoindre au sein du conseil de
sécurité
le fasse et veiller à ce que tout cela
se fasse en étroite liaison avec les
pays de la région pour éviter la
déstabilisation que vous avez pointé
dans votre question comme un risque réel
la parole est à monsieur philippe
kaltenbach pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues madame la ministre de
l'égalité des territoires du logement
vous le savez je lis dernier le 13
décembre
monsieur aux années vous a remis son
rapport sur la faisabilité du grand
paris express
ce métro automatique autour de paris
comme cela était malheureusement
prévisible il a tout d'abord confirmé
les approximations dont s'est rendu
coupable le précédent gouvernement dans
l'évaluation financière du projet eh oui
l'estimation du coût global a fait un
bond
de près de 50% elle est passée de 20
milliards à 30 milliards d'euros
excusez du peu et quand je pense que
ceux qui ont commis cette erreur
grossière donnent aujourd'hui des leçons
il est pourtant indispensable que ce
projet se fasse la réalité des
conditions de transport des usagers nous
le rappellent quotidiennement et le
grand paris express doit se faire avec
la cohérence et l'envergure que nous
voulons pour ce nouveau réseau de
transports collectifs
devant l'ampleur de la sous évaluation
du coût du projet par l'ancien
gouvernement
nous sommes conscients qu'un nouveau
phasage sera nécessaire il n'y a que
quelques démagogues pour réclamer que
tout le projet se fasse dans les délais
initiaux sans expliquer où trouver les
10 milliards d'euros supplémentaires
cependant les élus locaux de la région
capitale n'ont pas manqué de faire part
de leur inquiétude depuis la remise du
rapport aux années et de ses
propositions sur le phasage du projet
ces inquiétudes sont multiples et se
fonde essentiellement sur notre capacité
à ne pas saucissonné le projet afin de
lui conserver toute son efficacité au
sud est
elle porte sur l'interopérabilité entre
la ligne rouge et la ligne orange à la
station champigny centre et sur la
nécessité de réaliser l'arc sud jusqu à
noisy champs dans les délais prévus au
nord-est
ces inquiétudes vise le triangle de
gonesse à l'ouest
elle concerne la liaison entre concert
et nanterre afin d'assurer le bouclage
autour de paris madame la ministre
le réseau francilien accueille chaque
jour 8 millions de voyageurs dans la
longue liste des bombes à retardement
laissons les tiroirs par monsieur
sarkozy il ya ce surcoût de 10 milliard
d'euros les élus en prenne acte y voit
bien la nécessité de phase ii le projet
cependant si nous voulons réussir le
pari du grand paris express dans un
délai suffisamment raisonnable pour
répondre aux besoins d'un réseau
francilien dont la fréquentation s'est
accrue de 20% ces dix dernières années
nous sommes aussi conscients qu'il
faudra dégager de nouvelles ressources
madame le ministre même si les
arbitrages du gouvernement ne sont
attendus que pour le mois de février
pouvez-vous rassurer les élus locaux et
les sénateurs
qui souhaitent être concertée et
associés sur le phasage comme sur le
financement
la parole est à madame cécile duflot
ministre de l'égalité des territoires et
du logement
monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur kaltene bac je vous
remercie de votre question et de sa
précision je voudrais simplement redire
avec une certaine clarté ce qu'il en est
de ce rapport
j'ai diligenté le 1er septembre de cette
année un rapport auprès de monsieur
auzanais pour évaluer les coûts réels du
grand paris express coût réel qui
effectivement avait été sous-évalué pour
plusieurs raisons la première c'est
nécessairement une dérive monétaire
entre les euros 2008 et les euro 2012
le coût complet de la ligne orange qui
n'avait pas été bien évaluer le prix des
interconnexions aux réseaux de transport
existants qui malheureusement ne
figurait ni dans le budget des
opérateurs existants ni dans celui du
grand paris express et enfin une
actualisation compte tenu des évolutions
du projet de certaines gares auquel
tenait beaucoup les élus locaux voilà la
réalité vous l'avez dit
la différence est de 10 milliards
d'euros mais surtout je voudrais
indiquer à ceux qui pourraient mettre en
cause la volonté du gouvernement de ne
pas réaliser le projet tel qu'il avait
été prévu c'est-à-dire à l'échéance de
2026 que pour mettre ce projet dans cet
ordre là il faudrait donc trouver 10
milliards d'euros supplémentaires mais
il faudrait surtout réalisé 18 km de
métro par en chantier qui n'a existé
dans toute l'histoire
dans aucun pays au monde les annonces
qui avaient été faites à ce sujet sur le
nombre de tunneliers disponible et une
maîtrise ouvrage était tout simplement
intenable et je pense qu'il est beaucoup
mieux de le dire de le dire surtout si
et je veux vous rassurer rassurer pas
seulement les sénateurs et les
sénatrices pas seulement les élus locaux
mais surtout les dizaines de milliers de
citoyens franciliens qui ont participé
au débat public autour de ce projet ce
projet se fera
le premier ministre a redit le 30
octobre devant un certain nombre
d'acteurs de saclay que l'état viendrait
apporter les montants nécessaires au
financement du projet mais pour que
celui ci puisse être réalisé dans de
bonnes conditions
il faut le priorisés dans le cadre d'un
dialogue d'un équilibre avec l'en
des élus qui permettra de répondre à
tous les objectifs la desserte de
banlieue à banlieue le développement
d'un certain nombre de territoires le
désenclavement de certains territoires
qui comme clichy montfermeil par
ailleurs par exemple attend depuis 40
ans une desserte en transports en commun
nous ferons en sorte parallèlement de
remettre à niveau les transports en
commun existants notamment pour les
zones qui nous n'accueillerons pas dans
les toutes prochaines années
ce nouveau réseau de transport voilà la
volonté du gouvernement voilà celle de
la ministre que je suis allée ferme
elle est constante elle ne se laissera
pas emporter par des vaines polémiques
et je n'en alimenterait aucune néanmoins
je souhaite dire que pour la réalisation
de ce projet il faut le faire avec
sérieux avec méthode et dire la vérité
nous en avons fini avec les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
je vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 16h15
et voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité dernier jeudi avant la trêve
des confiseurs avant les fêtes de noël
et du 1er janvier bien sûr on se
retrouvera en janvier mais nous on
refait la séance dans quelques secondes
a tout de suite